"Blue Bloods" on CBS has a "who's
who" of talent in the cast,
not the least of which is TV legend Tom
Selleck as the family patriarch Frank Reagan.
To one generation of viewers, Selleck may be
best known for his role on "Magnum, P.I.,"
but his presence on "Blue Bloods" means he's
the rare actor with multiple iconic television
roles to his name. Many actors are lucky enough
to get just one, but then again, Selleck isn't
like most actors, and you can tell that's the
case by the way his co-stars talk about him.
Selleck may have years of acting experience
under his belt, far more than any other
performer on "Blue Bloods," but Donnie Wahlberg,
who plays Danny Reagan on the police procedural,
more than holds his own against him. The two
have had ample scenes together over the years,
so suffice to say, the two actors have had
numerous opportunities to get to know each
other. As expected, Wahlberg has nothing
but kind things to say about his co-star.
Considering Tom Selleck has decades
of experience in the industry,
it should come as no surprise to hear
that he's a delight to work with.
In an interview with Outsider, Donnie Wahlberg
let it be known that he adores working
alongside the veteran actor. He said,
"Tom [Selleck] is a leader himself. He is a very
experienced, very smart guy. Very dedicated,
much like myself. There are times
when we both see the hidden game,
and we both want the same thing but we
have very different ideas on how to do it."
It's a great sensation for an actor to go
up against someone who challenges them.
It prevents one from getting complacent, and
helps them strive to deliver another stellar
performance. Wahlberg goes on to describe how
it's almost like a dance between the two, saying,
"Knowing when to step up, knowing that this
is the time Tom could really use my input.
Or knowing when to step back and knowing
this is the time I gotta trust Tom.
It is very truthful off-screen as it
is on-screen for Danny and Frank."
Part of the reason why Selleck and Wahlberg
get along so well is because Wahlberg sees a
lot of his own father in Selleck's character.
In a 2013 interview with The Huffington Post,
Wahlberg spoke about what drew him
to "Blue Bloods" in the first place.
As one of nine children, Wahlberg could
relate to his character Danny as one of
a group of siblings who often squabble,
but always come together in the end.
Wahlberg said,
"'Blue Bloods' is a throwback show because
they don't make shows that focus on families
like this anymore. [...] Everything's focused
on the unusual family. When I read the pilot
the family dinner scene attracted me most. I've
felt the heat of my dad staring down at me and my
sister while we're arguing and that same heat's
there with Tom Selleck and Bridget [Moynahan]."
And it's not just the arguments
that remind Wahlberg of his own
family — it's the lighter moments too. He said,
"Just like we tease Tom on-screen, that's
directly from my childhood with my dad. He
was a very tough guy and we loved trying to break
through that hard exterior and make him laugh."
Wahlberg and Selleck's relationship has deepened
in the eleven years since "Blue Bloods" first
went on the air. In a recent interview
with Entertainment Tonight, which he gave
shortly after the death of his mother, Alma,
Wahlberg talked about his bond with Selleck.
"I call him dad now, and he calls me son. I mean,
that's how we talk to each other off-camera.”
With a show like "Blue Bloods," it
only works if the actors playing
a family can believably come off that
way. Luckily for Wahlberg and Selleck,
it doesn't sound like they have to fake
the father-son dynamic too much – and
that's one of the many reasons why "Blue
Bloods" has connected so well with fans.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.